Atchoo!
COLD MEDICINE
FOR: HARUO YAGUCHI
I finally got to stay home from school
but the fever is ruining my hidden agenda!
Mom...
Mom, I'm suffering here!
Bring me some water!
Refill my ice pack!
I want a hug--
What!
Ono! Why the heck are you
in my house?
That's no way to greet her!
Ono was on duty today
and brought you the handouts from school.
Did you hear him?
"I want a hug," he said.
-Can you believe it at his age--
-Oh man, kill me now...
With such a cute girl here for my Haruo,
I've got to be hospitable!
How about being hospitable to me...
Oh, man...
What cruel twist of fate is this?
Huh?
Ah, the handouts.
The classroom visit?
No way I'm bringing her.
What son would want to show
his parents his failures?
She would gape in horror
at my math grades...
SEE AN EYE DOCTOR
It's like I'm getting scolded
for playing too many games.
All you brought were depressing things.
Not one thing to cheer me up.
CHINA WARRIOR
Anyway...
if you don't need anything, just go home.
Sorry to keep you waiting!
It's Mama Haruo's special pancakes!
Just like in the manga comics!
How cute. What a little doll.
Come on, should you be giving a lady
something like that before dinner?
Well, I'm going shopping.
Don't do anything naughty!
As if we would!
Hey, Ono! Say something!
Don't fall for my mom's weird tricks!
Hey! What are you snooping for?
This is so obvious!
Ah! If you're going,
just leave already! Jeez!
Right away!
This is how she treats her feverish son?
You should leave once you finish that.
Why did my mom have to force her way in?